foreign
[Music]
our weekly entertainment and film
podcast and this is the TV version we're
going to be bringing you a condensed
version of what we've been talking about
this week and I'm joined by Sky's arts
and entertainment reporter Claire
Gregory hello hello and skies
entertainment producer Jason mansuri
hello and if you'd like to uh listen to
the long version the version in full of
our podcast just scan the QR code which
is on your screens at the moment coming
up
wanted man on the planet you know who
you're gonna take with you to see the
boys stupid are you still doing it what
do you think and if we're if we're going
to talk about shows that we really get
excited about after four years Black
Mirror is back and should we take a look
at the the kind of brief Snippets that
we're able to tease you about with Black
Mirror returning to Netflix
this guy had been a dutching people so
that's what your documentary is about
the details are so awful it is
irresistible
I love it
Claire you were lucky enough to uh talk
to Charlie Brooker of course we
associate him so much with this as one
of the sort of key creators of black
mirror as he like was exciting it was
incredibly sarcastic yes sarcastic
exactly what you want Oh Jennifer Cafe
is also kind of very honest and open and
chatty and you know it was really
interesting to kind of get a sense of
one of these episodes no spoiler to say
but one of them kind of tackles Ai and
the idea of um you know of how that sort
of infiltrating our normality and how
that's becoming a big thing for the for
the TV and film industry it's one of the
reasons the writers are on strike in
Hollywood right now is because of you
know issues around AI so I had to ask
him what do you think do you reckon that
you know our politicians here are they
doing enough to kind of get a handle on
this if Rishi sunak had been replaced by
AI I I probably wouldn't have noticed
um so
um uh so actually he'd be a good
character to pop up like you know the
paper clip that used to pop up in
Microsoft Word I'd like a little rishy
Sue neck that pops up and goes it looks
like you're writing about how depressing
the government is would you like some
help with that Charlie Vega always uh
pretty amusing no matter the uh subject
but what did you think of this series
because they've talked a lot about how
they're doing something different this
year is and one of the things they are
doing is more comedy that the first
episode of the series is no spoiler to
say it's funny it's that first episode
is the standout episode Jonah's awful
it's brilliant and it's got Salma Hayek
in it and um the the brilliant woman
from schitt's Creek why can't any Murphy
Annie Murphy yeah of course
um it's it's brilliant it's funny when
you go on to the next two episodes after
that it gets dark but boy does it get
dark this is my point with Black Mirror
though is I always have like a tension
about watching an apprehension because I
know it's gonna stress me out something
awful things
really awful is about to happen um but I
mean it's brilliant it's amazing and I
think even since back in the day when it
was um on Channel 4 in the UK even back
then it was incredible it um sort of
holding up a lens to our culture and
particularly popular culture and how we
look at Fame reality television all
those kind of things and I think it's
managed to continue doing that and
that's what I'll give it credit for but
I do find it like a horror I find it
stressful to watch
it's depressing at times Well if Black
Mirror is a bit too stressful for you
how about uh watching a bit of Marvel is
Marvel less stressful let's talk about
that shall we
um secret Invasion it's coming out now
on Disney Plus
things had gotten much worse
how do you think I came back
Claire you're the big Marvel fan here I
feel like we should start
with us I feel like I just occasionally
dip my toes what's eating about this is
different this isn't um you know like
Loki or like Wonder Vision this is more
like a political thriller when Star Wars
brought out and or I feel like this is
kind of the equivalent of that they're
trying to maybe reach us
there's a lot of chat not so much action
is that fair to say it's very cold it's
set in Russia
so I don't know what I feel I have to
put my coach on
um yeah it is a little bit slow though
no I don't think so I think it's uh I
think it's so well acted uh you've got
Olivia Coleman just every scene just
absolutely steals it steals it gives you
like amused entertained engaged it's
brilliant and Samuel Jackson of course
returns as Nick Fury and then you've
also got Ben mendelsohn uh Emilia Clark
from Game of Thrones in the car so
really really great acting and that
pulls you through maybe if you kind of
were hoping for a bit more in terms of
action don't worry because it's loads of
great uh acting instead
um and yeah Olivia Coleman totally
stealing the uh the the scenes I did
when I caught up with her about this I
did I have to ask about you know would
you all had you always wanted to be a
Marvel or was it this part that tempted
you how did it come about after every
Marvel release I'd phone my agent to say
I want to be in a Marvel and uh I don't
know if she had any say in it but it
eventually happened so yeah I'm thrilled
I think it's I think when you talk about
it being slow it isn't interesting to
remember that Samuel Jackson is 74 years
old and I don't necessarily want to see
him being Indiana Jones I want to see
him you know Nick theory is a bit slower
he do you want every scene to be either
somebody accusing Samuel Jackson of
being past it or other people talking
about how he's no threat because he's
passed it okay let's look at money then
I mean the reality is is that uh Disney
made two very big Acquisitions one for
Marvel for four billion and the other
one for Star Wars for about seven
billion it got a lot of slack for Star
Wars for 7 billion but you can see how
much they managed to put out and how
they managed to get that money back
again I think that's what's happening
here with Marvel and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the problem is that
when you have a Loki and you have a one
Division and you have all these series
come out something's got to be a little
bit flat and I think unfortunately this
might be the one I'm not saying it's fat
I don't agree this is really really good
it's just different but different can be
good too you know let we have to talk
about take that big return to the
cinemas now though with uh the movie
greatest days so the big star Talent the
name and this that you you will be
familiar with is comedian nationaling B
she's very good in there we hear her
singing for the first time here I am new
ladies
are up front because it's all done
basically uh with flashbacks to her and
her friends when they were in uh the 90s
a massive massive take that fans and
when she's an adult she wins tickets to
go and see them again doesn't she what
did you think oh it's just it's a heart
warmer and for those of a certain age
that really like to take that avoid eye
contact and still like take that I just
think it's like it's very it's Mamma Mia
Vibes for me if you love hearing those
songs that you love so much and it's
feel good it's light entertainment this
is you know it's not going to win Awards
and stuff but it's just a bit of fun
it's a it's a bit cheesy but it's a good
cheese bad face Jason
is not an agreement yeah I mean I think
I think what I preface this by saying at
the moment it's already running and it
will be running for many years to come
doing well the theater version of this
doing cruise ships and I think I think
that sort of says a lot about who it's
for who it's designed for what sort of
what sort of uh musical is um for film
for the screen and what kind of musical
it was uh for the stage look if anyone
likes to take that I would just say
block out the noise of Jason at the
moment because this is an entirely
enjoyable watch and I I had the great
pleasure of meeting the boys 13 year old
you sure 13 year old me is absolutely
like passed out now on the floor shall
we hear what Gary barley had to say to
me the one thing for us that was so
important with with the musical and the
movie the story was turning a mirror on
the audience and making it about them
and how important they are within what
we do look from one group of men dancing
on the stage to another
the full monty is uh being turned into a
TV show and it's out now on Disney plus
let's take a quick look everyone as
their ups and downs right when was the
last stop
it's about Destiny she's doing all right
like you know somebody's got to look out
for it who the hell are you to give out
parenting advice eh you don't even have
any kids
Claire look explain a bit about their
return 25 years after the original the
gang's all back together but crucially
this isn't a remake of the film this is
25 years on so we get to see of course
in the movie they they made their names
locally by you know turning into a male
stripping group and 25 years later
they're all still Pals they're all still
hanging out and they're kind of
navigating Modern Life in Sheffield and
maybe not always having the easiest time
of it is it just me or I have memories
of the original being a bit more edgier
than this there's a lot of shows that
this is similar to it feels like a kind
of less less funny version of brassic
but dare I say it it kind of gives off
kind of
um Last of the Summer why
and a bit of Waterloo Road it is also
trying to say something about
um
socioeconomics and social commentary
yeah yeah yeah a bit more but uh do we
need it I don't know that's my problem
and I think I would just maybe rather
just go back and watch the film it was
such a great movie I've enjoyed this
week thank you guys thank you can we do
it again next week yeah yeah we'll chat
again to you soon take care